Pera Mahoney is our next speaker and
clears three-minute thesis title is
making plastics hot I just want to say
one word to you
plastics there's a great future in
plastics this is my favorite quote from
the movie The Graduate because even
Dustin Hoffman in the 1960s knew that
there was a great future in plastics and
it makes sense because plastics are
great they're easily processable they're
economically viable and they're
versatile they make luxuries like
iPhones more affordable to necessities
like prosthetics more affordable to
people that previously couldn't afford
it and they permeate almost every facet
of our lives from the Pens we write with
to the socks on our feet plastics or in
other words polymers however are not
perfect let's take for example looking
at their microstructure your average
plastic looks closer to a loose pile of
spaghetti than it does to a knight
nicely ordered material like a metal
wood and because of this this limits
where polymers or plastics can actually
be applied to which is why we don't see
things like plastic pots or pans however
where the average person would see
limitations a good target sees
opportunity
now it's already been shown that adding
adding particles to plastic or
stretching plastic can increase the
thermal conductivity but why and by how
much no one really knows so this is
where I come in
the mummy the main focus of my work is
to actually look at plastics and see
what determines the thermal conductivity
and by how much oh by the way thermal
conductivity is essentially the
materials ability to transmit heat so
because much thanks to Chris mano cesky
of our chemistry department here at CMU
we actually have a technique called a
TRP that allows us to make polymer
chains a very well-defined link identity
and structure so I use this technique to
create side by side plastic systems that
have one isolated parameter different
between them say for example the shape
of my polymer or the interaction
energies between them and I see just how
much that one parameter changes the
thermal conductivity in our systems what
I've found so far is that when we
introduce favorable mixing or elongate
those chains we can get significant
increase in our thermal conductivity
seen in our plastics when compared to
the neutral or the unstretched polymer
counterparts if we figure out what
parameters affect thermal conductivity
in plastics we can learn how to optimize
thermal conductivity if we can make
thermally conductive plastics we can do
anything from making affordable
computers or much more affordable
computers to flexible cell phones but
really the possibilities are endless
because there's a great future in
plastics so think about it will you
think about it
you